[Music]
for generations of Americans toys-r-us
was the place for bikes trains and video
games but last night it all ended when
the last Toys R Us stores closed for the
final time it's something that I grew up
with and to see it now empty it's just
sad and heartbreaking Toys R Us was
founded by Charles Lazarus in 1948 the
company grew to become the biggest toy
seller in America with more than 800
store locations but in March
Toys R Us announced it would shutter its
remaining stores following years of
financial struggles increasing
competition and flagging sales this is
probably a story more about
mismanagement over the course of a
couple of decades not just a digital
story it's not just Amazon 8 our
business it's that we did a deal with
too much debt we weren't smart enough to
expand our online footprint fast enough
and we mismanaged the process as shelves
began to empty and doors began to close
tributes and memories of Toys R Us or
shared online meanwhile the chains
liquidation has left some employees with
hard feelings about 31,000 workers were
told they would not receive severance
pay as part of the bankruptcy agreement
but the toys-r-us name may not be gone
for good it and trademarks like its
mascot Jeffery will be auctioned off
next month so sad yeah one really nice
note out of Raleigh they closed their
store early because an anonymous donor
bought a million dollars worth of toys
bought him out and was donating them to
local there's a great store that was
such Santa's workshop for me my dad
would drop me and my sister off and we
just go to town dream about a Barbie
Dream House whatever
where's our us kids yeah